handmade roman sandals strong patterns
in bold combinations and everything just
a little over the top
that's what fausto pulisi has in mind
for urban gladiators next spring and
summer
in his current collection the fashion
designer flirts with his italian
origins this is beautiful because it's
all handmade and it's one of the
gladiator things and i love it so much
because it's really an italian
masterpiece then i go back to my roots
and they say okay let's start to study
the roman mosaics which are amazing all
these geometrical patterns all these
geometrical designs
and i wanted to translate on prints i
wanted to translate as well
on knitwear and with a three-dimensional
effect
palesi has always had a weakness for
geometric shapes
last year in paris he showed a complete
collection under his own name for the
first time
with great success
international stars quickly took to
wearing his dresses
such as american actresses cameron diaz
and jennifer lopez
and new zealand singer lord
palisi became a favorite of celebrities
when he designed the costumes for pop
star madonna's stage shows in 2012.
celebrities this much more a way of
having fun because they love them
because they want to be beautiful they
want to be sexy they want to be the best
and they want to be the best and they
like to do the best and
i like to play with them for this but
they like normal women all the women
celebrities not celebrities i like
everybody
and the fans love his eye-catching
designs
polizzi is considered one of the most
promising young italian designers
fashion journalists are already calling
him the new gianni versace
his shows attract the industry's movers
and shakers such as anna wintour
editor-in-chief of the american edition
of vogue anna de la rosso creative
consultant for vogue japan takes credit
for discovering it
that comes to the fore here not so much
the rocker aspect that fausto became
famous
the reason why i think he's so exciting
is because he's proposing something that
no one else does and he has his own
universe with this optical geometric
prince there was a lot of black and
white but he gave it a spurt of color
and he's not afraid of being over the
top
palesi was interested in fashion even as
a child but he got his big break two
years ago
when paris-based fashion house onaro
named him their creative director
in 2013 he presented the first
collection of his own label in milan
for two years now the milan boutique joe
moretti has been carrying his
collections and his label is now
represented in 31 countries
a pulisi dress can go for between one
and ten thousand euros
many customers come looking for the
designer's newest pieces
i always feel good in his clothes i can
wear them for any occasion with sporty
shoes during the day or with elegant
ones in the evening
critics have suggested that pulizzi
copies versace
both love glitter and guttiness but
polizzi says he found his own style long
ago
i want to be myself it's my amazon it's
my story it's i want it's i want to it's
possibly easy it's me
it's my dream i want to be me
fausto polizzi has no qualms about
casting a biker jacket all in gold
his new collection also includes pieces
that would seem right at home on a
starlet's hips